Cables are traditional favorites
for both machine and hand knitters.
Here are a few tips for success
on your knitting machine.
The basic move to cross cables
is to use two transfer tools,
remove the first set of stitches on one
of the tools and turn it 90 degrees.
Then remove and transfer
the adjoining stitches.
Replace the held stitches on the empty
needles and your cable is crossed.
Because our knitting is stretched across
the needle bed, it can be
difficult to form cables sometimes.
Using a looser tension than you might
normally choose for your yarn
and knitting with a yarn
that's a bit stretchy can help.
Following are some other
suggestions that will help as well.
Now, let's get started with this example,
and we're going to cross a three by three
cable, three stitches over three stitches.
Now, you can see the strain on the
stitches as they're being transferred.
And if you look closely, the needles
are also pulled a bit out of alignment.
That can cause some problems knitting.
Working two by two cables would be easier,
but there are things you can do
to improve this three by three.
Looking at on the right side of the work,
you have the texture of the cables,
but something's missing.
Normally, you see a column or two of pearl
stitches on either side of the cable,
giving the fabric much more texture
and making those cables pop.
There's an easy way for machine knitters
to accomplish this look by simply leaving
a needle out of work
on each side of the cable.
In our example, we're again
a three by three cable.
We have a needle out of work,
there are six needles in work,
and then a needle out of work.
This time when we cross our cable,
there's less strain on those edge
stitches, and the cables
are a bit easier to cross.
Looking at the finish side,
this is a traditional looking cable
that seems to pop right off
the surface of the knitting.
But you may not like the ladders
along the edge of your cables.
Here's a better method.
I've identified and marked
the needles for my cable.
I'm going to drop one stitch on either
side of the six cable needles.
Now, when I cross my cable, there's a lot
of slack, and the crossing isn't tight.
But you'll see that those
stitches have run down.
Now,
before I knit the next row,
I need to latch up those drop stitches,
forming a column of pearl stitches
on either side of the cable.
So after you latch up,
just rehang those single stitches
on the empty needle,
and then you're ready
to knit across the row.
I'm knitting eight rows, and then
I'm going to cross another cable.
Now, here's a really neat trick.
Before I drop the stitches on each side
of the cable, I use a stitch marker or
a Knitter's coil-less pin and secure
the last stitch that I manually
formed on the previous cable.
Now, when I drop those stitches,
they're only going to run down
to the point of the marker,
and then I can grab that stitch
and more easily relatch the column.
Looking at the cables from the right side,
they are beautiful.
No large ladders and a neat pearl column
makes that cable really stand out.
If you're following a pattern with cables,
remember that machine knitters are viewing
their knitting from the private
or the wrong side of the work.
You have the pearl side facing you.
So study your stitch chart carefully.
If you're following a hand knitting cable
pattern,
They're drawn as if you're viewing
the work from the public or
the right side of the work.
In this example, with this chart,
the cable will cross from left to right.
Again, read your pattern carefully
and study the direction of the cross
before starting a garment.
Better yet, work a swatch to confirm
the direction of the crosses.
If you love cables and would like
to learn more, we recommend four books.
Susan Guayumi's Hand Manipulated Stitches
for Machine Knitters
and More Hand Manipulated Stitches
books are invaluable and inspirational.
Everything you ever wanted
to know about cables.
Take time to try cables for yourself.
Have fun and happy knitting.